Matthew Knowles denies having a feud  with his daughter Beyonce over rights to  the Destiny's Child grand second name  say my name recent reports by In Touch  magazine claimed that queen bee plans to  sue her father over ownership to the 90s  girl group that jump-started her solo  career in an exclusive statement to ET  Knowles slams the supposed lawsuit these  dangerous rumors defame my family name  they have no validity and holds no merit  they're founded by rumor mills who like  to kick up sales especially during the  holidays there are many other important  topics needing America's attention  Knowles tells ET he is quote focusing on  lectures and seminars ones geared toward  helping new artists become a superstar  like Beyonce although Beyonce's dad  still owns the rights to DC's name and  music he says he is focused on creating  another successful girl group Knowles is  set to debut a new female rap group  called blush in 2016  you